hey what is up guys i'm kphd here and
welcome to what i'm pretty sure is the
biggest
tech
youtube giveaway probably ever so i'm
teaming up with my good friend lou from
unbox therapy and the folks from lg
actually who we kind of need to make
this giveaway happen so as you can tell
by the title it's an lg g3 giveaway but
it's not just your ordinary g3 giveaway
we needed to team up with the folks at
lg because we're not just giving away
one lg g3 like you saw in my review
video but we're also not just giving
away two or not just not just five
or
ten
or
twenty we're actually giving away
75 lg g3s 75 of these phones are going
to be up for grabs to people who follow
the rules and they're going to be super
simple for this giveaway so the rules
are going to be structured pretty
similar to giveaways i've done in the
past lou and i have both uploaded a
video today and once you're a subscriber
of both of our channels i'll have an
annotation here to subscribe to mkbhd
and to subscribe to unbox therapy once
you're a subscriber all you have to do
is leave a comment below each of our
videos to get entered one comment on
each video will count that's it and i
might as well leave an interesting
comment something about the phone why
you want to win one of the g3s something
about maybe if you watch the review you
like the screen or the battery or the
software just something interesting
about the phone uh to keep it
interesting now once you've entered all
you got to do is kick back relax and
wait until friday july 18th which is
when the giveaway will close the comment
section will close and we'll keep you
guys updated on twitter if there's
anything else that changes between now
and then which hopefully there won't but
again this giveaway will not end early
it will end on the 18th and we'll be
announcing all the winners basically by
updating the description of this video
because there will be 75 winners
selected randomly from the comments
section but that is basically it again
if you have any questions about the
rules they'll all be linked right below
the like button all the description is
filled with exactly the information you
need and while you're at it you might as
well check out the lg g3 review just to
know what you're getting into just to
know what you're getting yourself into
these are in fact the korean models
they're actually still pretty early in
production you can't get these in the
united states yet but lg figures to give
75 of you a hands-on exclusive
experience with the lg g3 they're going
to give away 75 of the korean model so
the exact model that you guys are going
to be getting if you win is what i
featured in my g3 review video i think
this is probably the biggest tech
youtube giveaway video i've ever done or
been a part of and i'd like to thank you
guys for making this even possible and
i'd like to thank lg for making this
possible as well uh they've been a huge
help so thumbs up for an awesome
giveaway good luck to everyone who is
commenting to enter thanks for watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
video
peace
[Music]
you